here now with reaction is the author of
the upcoming book come on man
fox news contributor joe koncha along
with uh former massachusetts senator
scott brown and fox and friends uh
weekend co-host rachel campos duffy uh
scott let me start with you because when
i hear about
the importance of keeping a gas high in
oil high because we're fighting putin
through ukraine
isn't it true that as long as the oil
prices are high
putin is getting even more money and
this is funding his adventurism that the
way to stop him would be in fact to
bring oil prices down not to keep them
high
well we know when oil was below 50 40
dollars a barrel and even less that
russia was hurting yes you're absolutely
right but you know this liberal new
world order another clueless biden
representative uh
newsflash uh the world is not all
liberal there are certain parts of the
world that are but the in the united
states of america which is where we are
we need to focus on our needs and not
other people's needs right now we're
paying uh now a little less because it's
independence day weekend so that you
know doing the manipulation but i just
paid 5 15 last week came back a dollar
72 and i got back from being the
ambassador in new zealand and and
tammy it's no secret here uh the the
president biden said that he was going
to end fossil fuels in america well i
guess that's okay that he's doing a good
job but i guess he doesn't really care
about the other parts of the world
because he's going to venezuela
obviously dealing with iran dealing with
the saudis making their oil industries a
booming industry so he's creating jobs
everywhere else but here yeah 38
approval rating rating 85 percent of the
people say we're going in the wrong
direction and he's got to get his act
together this administration is is
doomed and it's it's not doing anything
right
yeah dooming all the rest of us with it
joe the title of your book is perfect
because it really it should be our
explanation it's like come on man you
saw his performance there embarrassing
at nato uh
noting
you know the the nature of as long as
this takes making a fool of himself but
also harming our national security in
the meantime what's your take on what
biden's up to at this point
besides that tammy everything went great
right scott put up that stat before uh
about 85 percent of voters don't like
the direction of the country i'd love to
do some keg stands over the weekend with
those 15 who thinks things are going in
the right direction who are these people
uh but but seriously
you see now the press is turning on mr
biden i keep reading uh you know that
should have happened the minute he
actually tried to sell the country on
this notion that if you spend trillions
upon trillions of additional dollars on
top of the trillions we already have and
you flood the system somehow he made
this argument that that will lower
inflation in the deficit and brian dees
who somehow is the chief economic
advisor to the president of the united
states he said the quiet part out loud
right that this is all intentional the
attempted transitioning of this economy
and energy policy to the new liberal
world order it sounds like something out
of the you know star wars senate i i
guess that's the plan fortunately tammy
we have elections in this country and
come november as many democratic
strategists will tell you voters are
overwhelmingly going to reject this
liberal world order and restore order to
the political universe so we have that
going for us which is well we we
certainly hope so because you know the
system seems to be effectively fine with
what's going on rachel
this is what i get concerned about is
that there are people running the
administration it's clearly not joe
biden and they think all of this is fine
they keep putting him in front they keep
arranging you know
whether it's like this kind of a press
conference where he refused to really
take many questions at all
so there's people within the
establishment that are moving this along
is that something we need to be
concerned about post november and the
midterms
of course there's three years left of
this administration so yeah we can put
the brakes on it in the midterm but
believe me there is a lot more damage
that can be done i do like that this guy
slipped up and told the truth because
remember tammy we were called conspiracy
theories theorists when we talked about
you know the liberal world order or we
said the great reset we know it's true
now they are totally willing to
impoverish us and it's not just because
they have you know an obsession with
environmentalism and they want to
transition us to fossil fuels out of
fossil fuels and into you know uh
energies that will make us more
dependent on china yes that's part of it
but it is bigger it is a great reset
they are trying to give us um you know
what uh
klaus schwab wants at davos um with the
world economic forum which is a chinese
system a social credit score a chinese
type of capitalism where the top
has capitalism and and and wealth the
elites the state and the rest of us live
under socialism this is a big big deal
but we're starting to see the curtain
open up and we're starting to see behind
and we know what's going on yeah scott
doesn't it matter as a result
who gets elected in november the
statement the volume of the statement
that is made in the midterm elections is
that in your time in washington and as
an ambassador have you found that that's
the thing that makes a difference when
it comes to what politicians are willing
to do like maybe finally listen to the
american people
yeah listen it's going to be a very
serious warning shot especially leading
into the presidency
everyone's saying there's going to be
this huge red wave well that's true if
we don't screw it up like we tend to do
and not unite behind the candidate who
may not be your candidate but it's it's
a republican who may be according to
ronald reagan you're 60 70 80 percent
friend not your 100 percent friend or a
100 percent enemy is as he would say but
listen uh you find just getting back to
something we said earlier about the
press you know listen my wife is a
former journalist and uh you know i have
a lot of respect for the press but you
got to do your job according bill
belichick just do your job hold him
accountable between the cue cards and
and the the the the ushering in and out
and the amazing handling of the
president it is embarrassing it's
dangerous it's affecting our national
security uh and and it's got to stop but
when we look at the farm team behind it
we're going to go to harris
pelosi no we have some very serious
issues and we need somebody strong to
deal with them and we're not yeah look
joe and this is your bailiwick in a
sense with the media isn't him have
biden having a list of people that he
goes to doesn't that tell us that the
media is colluding effectively with the
biden administration in you know making
sure they know if certain someone is
picked on and chosen for a question that
it's either going to be easy or there's
not going to be a hard follow-up or that
person can be trusted isn't that part of
the problem here with the especially
with the white house press corps they
complain about access but my goodness
haven't they been facilitating this
debacle
yeah it's funny when you mentioned
access tammy that uh the guy who was
president before joe biden was probably
the most successful president uh that
that we've ever had right he took more
questions
then probably his three predecessors
combined sometimes sometimes press
conference is going on for two and a
half uh hours and and yet the press
complained that you know he was trying
to destroy the free press well i'm
pretty sure uh compared to what we're
seeing now with this president who from
day one has had that list and then is
smart enough to share oh by the way they
gave me a list of reporters that i have
to call on again saying the quiet part
out loud but it's not just joe biden and
and scott touched on it just a second
ago as far as the farm team try get a
try getting a flight somewhere this
weekend without it being canceled or
greatly postponed or costing you a
fortune because we have a transportation
secretary and pete boudej who's supposed
to be maybe the plan b who has no
business being in this position as
transportation secretary who doesn't
have a clue how to fix the problem
despite his you know vast experience as
the mayor of a small town in indiana
tammy so yeah that's that's the whole
team in general it's not just biden it's
all the adults that are supposed to be
back in the room and it's amateur hours
let me tell you the the two people that
represent the democrat party the
democrat base really are kirsten cinema
and joe manchin so this is that is the
answer for them but my goodness the
condition they're in now is quite a
disaster joe rachel scott thank you so
much for joining me tonight now hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else